make no mistake this is a historic day
for Afghanistan the United States and
the Taliban seal a deal after almost 19
years of war but will it be remembered
as the start of a genuine path to peace
or does this mark a u.s. sprint for the
exit America's top diplomat that he came
to the signing ceremony here in the Gulf
State of Qatar to witness history not a
Taliban victory lap if the Taliban do
not uphold their commitments President
Trump and his team will not hesitate to
do what we must do to protect American
lives if on the other hand the Taliban
abide by their promises the United
States will undertake our responsible
conditions-based
troop withdrawal his former foe focused
on the American exit rather than
compromises the Taliban has made I hope
that we do withdrawal of all foreign
forces from Afghanistan that the Afghan
nation under the an Islamic regime will
take its relief and embark on a new
prosperous life this is why the United
States backed by Britain invaded his
country in the first place
the September 11 attacks of 2001
launched by al Qaeda from Taliban
controlled Afghanistan the regime was
toppled but an insurgency that followed
became America's longest war it's one
president Trump is keen to end
especially in an election year but he'll
now need his Afghan counterpart to
navigate direct talks with the Taliban
Ashraf Ghani led a complementary peace
deal ceremony in Kabul today can be the
moment of overcoming the past our people
can mark get assess the time when our
quest for sustainable and dignified
peace moved from desirability to
feasibility
in credibility both for the living
generations in the future generations to
come
words Afghans want to hear but many are
fearful I get doubt on its holla for UK
life was not good during the time of the
Taliban today we have free life they ban
women from getting an education so what
kind of conditions will the Taliban come
back with lots of questions too few
answers Afghanistan's future still
uncertain Deborah Haines Sky News